nah man um I don't really I don't really
feel it i'm in a position to say what
kind of president Hillary would be or
Barack Obama would be I am so delighted
that the Democratic Party you know it
has this contest between a woman and an
african-american and I think that that
makes us a great country even if nobody
believed it before we are a great
country and I think that they would both
be very good presidents I think I don't
think that anybody who is currently
running for that office would be a bad
president I think that you you you have
too many people helping you there's too
much there's too many people whispering
in your ear the question is are you the
kind of person who's going to listen to
those or are you going to be you know
you're going to be unilateral in your
decision making no question that she's
bright and experienced and would be a
great leader the question is not that
the question is who is the country going
to love you know that presidents you
know all things being equal they're
going to vote for the person that they
care about them also they have an
emotional connection to right now it
looks like Barack Obama is getting most
of that emotional connection because he
is more in touch with his female side
than she is you know in that kind of
compassion in that kind of warmth that
he exudes is very you know it's very
appealing to people that's what they
won't let mean you don't remember
because the audience out there who's
watching this will not remember but when
John F Kennedy ran for the presidency in
1960 he was a junior senator from
Massachusetts nobody knew him he didn't
have any experience but he captured the
imagination of the American people and
he won the election it's kind of what's
happening now I think in a way
you